for liberal elites they do not need to
practice what they preach they don't
even need to pretend
to practice what they preach
aoc oh my gosh did she prove this aoc
has a shop and she sells merchandise
so at shop.ocasiocortez.com
aoc the socialist darling of america
is selling a tax the rich sweatshirt
for just about 60 bucks tax the rich
but you have to be rich to buy the shirt
and the people who support aoc tend to
be
pretty rich because she is not just a
representative
from new york in the federal government
she is in a way a priestess
of the fashionable liberal
policy that is taken for religion by a
great many people
other merch you can buy it's a new deal
a new green new deal mug
for 27 bucks you can get a drink water
and don't be racist
t-shirt okay for 27 bucks
you can get a cancel student debt
t-shirt for 27 bucks if you're buying 27
t-shirts probably you don't have a lot
of student debt or you do and you're
just hoping that somebody will pay your
debts for you
you can buy an abolish ice hat
for 28 bucks and then i love this is my
favorite one
social economic racial justice
sweatshirt 65 bucks
that is magnificent daily wire actually
who i don't know who it was somebody on
our team came up with
this new daily wire sweatshirt that
they're selling and it says
insert woke slogan here or something to
that effect and
in the same font as aoc's and we're
selling it for cheaper than she was like
10 or 20 bucks cheaper
so anyway you can go over to
dailywire.com right now we're selling
those
to me that's a much more beautiful uh
sweatshirt
this is a group of people
who who are forcing an ideology on the
rest of us
that they do not believe themselves
whether it's aoc or whether it's the
politicians
with the lockdowns this is a cynical
strategy
employed by hypocrites and and
a lot of politicians throughout history
there's nothing new about that
but we have absolutely no obligation to
go along with that
the politicians foisting these mandates
on us have made it clear
they don't believe it they are not
living in fear of the virus remember
president trump came out said don't live
in fear of the virus and the entire
liberal establishment came out and said
yes you should be afraid curl up in your
room
don't see your family stay home let us
destroy the economy and take away your
civil rights
i don't think there was much of an
argument to do that even if the virus
were as bad as everyone was saying it is
even if it were as deadly and it's
obviously
not the the survival rates are much much
much much higher than the
liberal elites have been letting on to
people
but if it were if it were legitimate
maybe there's some argument you know in
some crazy extreme circumstance
but there isn't an argument now these
people don't believe it
you should stop heeding these stupid
lockdowns you should stop
keeping your business closed you should
stop wearing that stupid mask in public
all the time
you should if you want to behave with
prudence and responsibility
then yeah exercise your faculties of
prudence and you know if you
if you really think that putting on the
cloth mask is going to help you in
certain narrow circumstances okay fine
whatever
but as a public matter these lockdowns
are completely preposterous
you should disobey them all the time as
much as humanly possible
[Music]
[Music]